[Musique]
bonsoir seller d'auditions publiques
ravive de vous retrouver pour ce rendez
vous hebdomadaire sur lcp public sénat
avec le figaro une heure de débat en
direct de confrontation aussi une heure
pour aller sur le fond des enjeux pour
tout comprendre pour réfléchir on en a
besoin
quand tout va trop vite et pour ouvrir
cette saison 2019 2020 note première
éviter jacqueline gourault bonsoir vous
êtes ministre de la cohésion des
territoires et des relations avec les
collectivités territoriales vice
présidente du modem par ailleurs merci
d'être avec nous au cours de cette
émission vous allez être interrogé par
mes consoeurs des chaînes parlementaires
lcp et public sénat deux parlementaires
à député un sénateur qui nous
rejoindrons tout à l'heure et puis pour
conclure
yves thréard du figaro nous rejoindra il
nous dira un peu ce qu'il a pensé de
tout ce que vous avez dit plus on aura
aussi des questions à vous poser vous le
verrez sans oublier les questions que
nos téléspectateurs peuvent nous faire
parvenir soit sur le figaro live soit
sur le compte twitter de l'émission avec
le hashtag auditions publiques et
j'aurais ici toutes les questions que je
pourrai relier ici sur ce plateau à
l'antenne ma première question
elle concerne daniel cueff vous le
connaissez c'est le maire de langoat en
ille et vilaine qui était de nouveau
devant la justice aujourd'hui parce
qu'il a pris un arrêté anti pesticides
qui interdit d' qui interdisait parce
que ça a été annulé depuis d'étendre des
pesticides à moins de 150 mètres des
habitations
ça a été annulé par le préfet il est
devant le tribunal ce mr le délibéré
c'est dans quinze jours seriez-vous
choqué qu'il soit condamné
d'abord première chose je crois qu'il
faut dire que le gouvernement partage
je dirais les inquiétudes que ce mr à
transformer si je puis dire on arrêté
municipal
la preuve en est c'est que ma collègue
elisabeth borgne a lancé comme vous le
savez un projet de décret qui
effectivement mettrait en place des
distances par rapport aux habitations
pour les cultures et il ya une
concertation assez large qui va être
prise et qui devrait être prise au mois
de janvier 2020 c'est-à-dire
prochainement
a été un bon lanceur d'alerté pas au
fond quelque part c'est un appel qu'il
entend d'ailleurs on peut admettre cette
cette idée c'est vrai qu'en l'état du
droit n'est ce pas il n'a pas respecté
la loi c'est ça que je veux dire dont il
était condamné ça vous choque réparé et
non non en l'état du droit qui est ce
que ça vous choquerait qu'ils soient
condamnés en l'état du droit il n'a pas
respecté la législation actuelle alors
ceci dit ça pose une question
moi qui suis je dirais en train de
préparer une loi décentralisation
également des concentrations etc et
différenciation
j'ai déjà dans l'esprit si je puis dire
d'envisager de proposer peut-être des
déconcentrations du du règlement c'est à
dire donner aux collectivités
territoriales la possibilité d'avoir un
pouvoir réglementaire jeu de rôle et en
exemple on est revenu je vais prendre un
exemple concret les maires ont déjà un
pouvoir réglementaire dans le cadre de
l'urbanisme
on pourrait imaginer qu'ils puissent la
voir dans le domaine de la transition
énergétique et de l'envié dans
l'environnement
je vous repose la question vraiment
rapidement est ce que vous seriez choqué
qu'il soit condamné mais oui non si vous
voulez à cette question que vous me
posez brutalement ne peut pas être une
réponse pour oui ou non
écoutez bien sûr il n'a pas respecté la
loi donc au regard de la loi
il ne l'a pas respectée mais je vais pas
me réjouir que cet élu qui est comme
vous le dites plein de bon sens et qui
veut protéger sa population soit
condamné on va cueillir maintenant
brigitte boucher de lcp est à mme tran
huy de public sénat qui vont vous poser
des questions à leur tour parce qu'elles
ont beaucoup de choses à vous demander
concernant notamment le premier sujet
et quand je dis le premier sujet ça
concerne le voile islamique qui revient
dans le débat bonsoir teinte nuit dans
soir brigitte boucher cvo brigitte qui
commençait bonsoir jacqueline gourault
ou plusieurs voix légèrement
discordantes se sont exprimées dans la
majorité sur le port du voile lors des
sorties scolaires à cause des propos
tenus ce week-end par un élu rn vous
quel est votre avis sur ces propos tenus
par un élu et rennes est est-ce qu'il
faut porter le voile lors des sorties
scolaires ou pas d'abord il ya deux
choses il ya la forme la manière dont
cela a été fait l'interpellation public
de cette femme qui était avec des
enfants et avec son enfant était assez
violente
si je puis dire et le fait que ce cet
élu diffuse lui même sur les réseaux
sociaux
l'enregistrement qu'il a fait faire
prouve bien que il était dans une
démarche de enfin politique je dirais
après sur le fond moi je crois que la
question se pose d'une pédagogie si je
puis dire qui pourrait être fait quand
il y a un déplacement avec des enfants
dans une enceinte qui est une enceinte
politique qui est donc une enceinte
républicaine puisque c'était au conseil
régional de bourgogne franche comté
peut-être qu'on devrait penser avant
s'il vient de faire de la pédagogie et
de dire il serait mieux en termes je
dirais de valeurs républicaines et de
laïcité que des femmes ne portent pas le
voile savez les règles ne sont pas les
mêmes partout dans l'hémicycle du
conseil régional de bourgogne les femmes
voilées peuvent assister à la séance
elles peuvent aussi faire à l'assemblée
elles ne peuvent pas le faire au sénat
lorsqu'il ya séance donc dans quel sens
faut-il tranché selon vous est-ce qu'il
faut que tous les règlements va
s'adapter aux je crois que ça serait
bien qu'il y ait une plus grande comment
dire
plus grands une cohérence parce que
c'est vrai que voilà on ne peut pas
forcément savoir donc c'est pour ça que
j'ai parlé de pédagogie mais dans quels
sont les symptômes
traduit dans quels sont ils autorisés
c'est un sujet extrêmement sensible
comme vous le savez et c'est un sujet
qui mérite qu'on le traite de façon posé
et calme comme cela a été fait car si
c'est pas dans quel sens du coup est-ce
que c'est plutôt l'interdiction le nom
de léo saignât vous allez le nom du nom
du principe de laïcité je pense qu'il ne
faut pas porter le voile dans les
ascensions absolument
mais donc c'est le règlement intérieur
qui doit être modifié on vous pensez
qu'il faut légiférer qu'il faut aller
plus loin dans la salle règlement
intérieur suffi et il y à un accord
entre les deux assemblées je trouve que
ça serait bien parce que vous savez
légiférer sans arrêt n'est pas toujours
la solution non plus d'ailleurs il va y
avoir une proposition de loi au sénat
qui va être examinée à la fin du mois
une proposition de loi de jacqueline
eustache brinio qui veut interdire le
port du voile aux accompagnatrice de
sorties scolaires est ce que vous vous
êtes favorable dans ce cas là je ne sais
pas si c'est elle ne se rende pas dans
un lieu public de la république il faut
réfléchir mais ça se discute ça ce débat
votre collègue jean michel blanc car il
est plutôt favorable d'ailleurs ce avait
été adoptée avec un as et pas
souhaitable dans le projet de loi écoles
de la cohésion
on sait très bien que les principes de
la république et de la laïcité fond
qu'il faut éviter à tout prix d'avoir
comme on dit pour d'autres religions des
signes ostentatoires
bon c'est ça la laïcité alors après
voilà on cherche toujours à vous faire
dire des choses très précises et c'est
moi je pense qu'il faut une société
aussi apaisée qui respecte les religions
qui respecte très large a cédé domaine
du privé où c'est qu'ils respectent la
religion la laïcité au sens de la loi
1905 c'est le respect des religions
après nous vivons dans un climat
actuellement extrêmement sensible donc
il faut faire attention aux mots qu'on
appelle se pose aussi la question de la
radicalisation dans les services publics
parce que ça peut toucher les services
publics évidemment les
qui sont confrontés à ça tu entre nuit
oui justement jacqueline gourault de
contexte qui est le nôtre un poste
attentats quelles sont les mesures mises
en place pour lutter contre la
radicalisation des agents de service
public dans les collectivités
d'abord vous savez que chaque maire et
le patron de sa collectivité
c'est lui qui est le chef du personnel
il revient à chaque maire donc de
prendre les décisions qui lui semble
approprié alors après je ne suis plus à
l'association des maires de france
puisque je ne suis plus maire mais c'est
un sujet bien évidemment dont
l'association des maires de france pour
s emparer de vrai vous devrez sans
pareil sa part s'est déjà emparé par
rapport à la question des fiches s il ya
une certaine époque tous ces sujets
différents tableaux oui mais là vous
parlez de la radicalisation des
personnels alors bien sûr il ya une
société de vigilance comme le président
de la république l'a exprimé et chaque
maire doit être aussi vigilant sur ce
qui se passe dans sa mairie après il ya
des mairies très importante avait
beaucoup de personnel en fait peuvent
avoir accès maintenant aux fiches s par
exemple dans leur commune mais ce qui
devrait être automatiquement prévenu des
fichiers s de leur commune ne pas avoir
à faire la demande
c'est toujours le même débat qu'on a vu
cent fois dans toutes les lois à
l'assemblée nationale au sénat etc
il ya deux sujets il ya l'information
des mères et puis il y a les sujets du
renseignement et à partir du moment où
vous mais le renseignement
ça doit avoir un minimum de secret parce
que si vous mettez tout sur la place
publique peut faire confiance au maire
oui vous qu'on peut faire confiance au
maire mais je pense qu'il faut
simplement que les mères soit informé
quand il y a un problème particulier si
vous mettez les fichiers open si je puis
dire ouvert à tout le monde ça peut
poser un problème alors on va parler
maintenant d'un autre sujet parce que on
sait que c'est un sujet sur lequel vous
étiez plutôt prudente c'est celui de la
pma parce que voilà arrive le moment du
vote solennel
gilles bouge et où le vote solennel qui
aura lieu demain à l'assemblée nationale
en première lecture
les débats se sont relativement bien
passé
dans l'hémicycle de l'assemblée est ce
que du coup vous qui aviez quand même
des réserves sur la pma est ce que vous
êtes rassurés oui je suis rassuré et je
pense que le débat s'est passé de façon
très sereine et c'est ça qui est qui est
important après ça n'empêche pas de se
poser
personnellement un certain nombre de
questions
et moi je suis certaine que la société
d'ailleurs les sondages le prouvent à
évoluer sur sur ce sujet en même temps
je suis prudente toujours sur tous ces
sujets et je répète changer de nom c'est
pas que je n'ai pas changé d'avis non
vous n'avez pas changer notre jeu
je répète toujours la même chose je me
suis rangé à l'idée du vote de la pma
mais c'est quelque chose auquel je fais
très attention par mes convictions
personnelles et en tout cas il faudra
veiller où ils ont percé convictions
catholiques
oui voilà et en même temps je sais qu'il
y a eu beaucoup de souffrance dans la
vie qu'il faut répondre à un certain
nombre de souffrances mais il faut aussi
toujours protéger les enfants et c'est
quelque chose qui est pour moi très
important
on va parler d'une personne que vous
connaissez pas ce qu'elle était dans les
rangs du modem sylvie goulard depuis
elle a fait carrière ailleurs dernière
en date c'était la banque de france
avant éventuellement la commission de
bruxelles et puis la cantate rapidement
sylvie boulard rto qu'un pour la
commission européenne elle était aussi à
l'origine finalement de tout
les démissions qu'il y avait eu deux
ministres modem à l'époque là on raconte
que françois bayrou n'est pas fâché de
cet événement vous qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
écoutez il ya eu une décision qui a été
prise je n'ai pas de commentaire à faire
sur la décision qui a été prise par le
parlement européen le président d'angola
le jeu n'est pas à être gay ou triste il
y à une décision qui a été prise qui est
une décision politique je suis certaine
comme le président de la république l'a
dit qu'il y a eu des interférences
politiques qui ont joué voilà c'est
comme cela
la france quant à elle je pense que la
france évidemment doit choisir
maintenant un autre candidat et j'espère
que tout se passera
je suis sûre même que tout se passera
avec ce portefeuille important que la
france saura comment dire une
responsabilité importante au parlement
européen et vous vous aviez pas mis en
garde le président sur lequel a une
vraie nature comme ça moi
personnellement non mais françois bayrou
oui et vous aviez des doutes du cosmo
vous savez très bien c'est sur la place
publique je vais pas répéter ce que
françois que françois bayrou n'a pas été
entendue alors écoutez la pose problème
à écouter voilà c'est la vie donc y
aller ça lui a donné raison en quelque
sorte oui mais la france sort affaiblie
mais pourquoi voulez-vous me faire dire
absolument des mots que vous avez
préparé je vous dis c'est maintenant le
fait il faut trouver un autre candidat
pour ce portefeuille important de la
branche ballon là vous avez des idées il
y avait fort ne le permettrait pas
maintenant nombreux combattants
au moins c'est clair voilà moi c'est
clair on va parler aussi du statut de
l'élu parce qu'il ya beaucoup de choses
à étudier sur cette question parce que
les municipales arrive et il ya une
crise des vocations c'est parce qu'il ya
des élus qui se sentent en difficulté ou
pas parent sécurité qui demande aussi
des garanties thème traduit
effectivement ce projet de loi sur le
statut de l'élu qui est en cours
d'examen au sénat dans l'ensemble examen
est plutôt consensuel certains ont tout
de même dit on est passé de balances ton
maire aka georges tournay lui est ce que
ce texte a des visées aussi
électoralistes je vous avais repris d
expression que je ne supporte pas la
gauche sénatoriale ce sont des phrases
qui ont été dites très bien que la
semaine et je peux quand même dire que
je les supporte pas parce que je trouve
que c'est accuser à tort de jambes pour
accuser à tort des gens qui travaillent
depuis très longtemps pour
l'accompagnement
des missions des mers d'ailleurs je
n'aime pas non plus beaucoup le mot de
statut car en vérité ce ne sera pas un
statut ce sont des mesures pour
accompagner les élus dans l'exercice de
leur mandat
vous savez pas ce qu'il ya derrière une
ambiguïté c'est une fonction que d'être
mère ça n'est pas un métier
d'accord d'accord et donc je pense que
faire croire qu'il y aura faut choisir
si on veut des mères fonctionnaires on
change complètement de système mais la
culture française et vérité depuis la
révolution française c'est que au fond
quelqu'un qui a une profession il est
médecin et les paysans puissent être
mère en même temps donc il faut
accompagner tous ces gens dans
l'exercice de leur mandat mais dire que
c'est un statut comme c'est le cas par
exemple en allemagne
ça n'est pas vrai ça ne sera pas un
statut par contre il y à des mesures
dans ce projet de loi qui sont très
intéressantes pour accompagner les
maires la protection juridique la
formation beaucoup de choses qui sont
très importantes
wintek sous sol et municipales il ya des
tensions dans la majorité entre la
république en marche et le modem dans
certaines villes
évidemment bordeaux mais aussi rennes
metz marseille ou encore toulouse
est ce que vous allez parvenir à un
accord dans ces villes là et est ce que
ça va pas laisser des traces là où il y
aura pas d'accord alors il n'y aura pas
de désaccord entre le modem et et la
république en marche à l'issue des
municipales
ça veut dire l'arrêt magazine elle va se
retirer à perdre on ne sait pas du tout
dit ça la république en marche et le
modem n'auront pas toujours les mêmes
positions dans certaines villes mais
dans beaucoup de cas ils seront d'accord
et puis les élections municipales comme
vous le savez en deux tours on verra ça
selon le monde le modem aurait testé les
candidature borloo et busan à paris
est-ce que vous alors vous vous croyez
pas en benjamin griveaux est ce que vous
cherchez d'un côté je ne suis pas
informé de cette
affirmation je vais me dire que le
modèle va soutenir benjamin gaver qui
est le candidat investi par shauna a
formé de cette recherche recherche ou ce
sondage comme vous le dites et donc le
modem n'a pas encore pris position
il prendra position le jour via ma
besoin d'un troisième but personnel en
troisième mais moi je n'ai pas à me
prononcer personnellement on verra on
fera une délibération en commun une
petite question au passage parce que
c'est la question qu'on pose à tous les
ministres est ce que vous serez
candidate aux municipales
non je ne serai pas candidate en vue ni
même pas sur une liste même pas sur une
nuit pourquoi bien parce que j'ai été
élu pendant 31 ans
un mandat d'adjoint plus quatre mandats
de maire et que j'ai laissé mon poste de
maire en 2014
parce que je savais en plus qu' il y
avait le cumul de mandats et j'étais
sénatrice donc j'ai fait un choix et je
pense que j'ai de bon successeur et je
ne vois pas me présenter dans une autre
commune que celle où j'ai été maire
pendant six lancers d'entre nous on va
parler aussi bien de votre portefeuille
des relations avec les collectivités à
quelques jours du congrès de l'assemblée
des départements de france
le torchon continue à brûler en tout cas
pour dominique bussereau qui juge que le
gouvernement du président de l'assemblée
des départements de france qui juge que
votre coup pas le jeu le site d'un
hold-up envers les finances des
départements on rentre pas dans les
détails techniques mais déjà sur ce
terme quand il dit vous êtes coupable
c'est pas moi vous croyez
non le gouvernement très bien aller
alors pour d'abord je vais vous dire je
travaille toutes les semaines avec
l'association des départements de france
j'ai vu dominique bussereau encore ya
dix jours lundi dernier avec d'ailleurs
jean rené lecerf
le président du conseil départemental du
nord nous avons travaillé sur la réforme
fiscale due à la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation et nous avons travaillé
tranquillement et nous avons bien avancé
donc c'est à dire que ce qu'il vous dit
dans le bureau skis des l'expérience est
pas tout la même chose écoutez moi je
suis pas là mais a divisé les
collectivités locales et le gouvernement
je suis là au contraire pour que tout
fonctionne car j'ai une conviction
profonde profonde
c
deux en france on avance sur les
territoires aussi il y à l'alliance de
l'état et des collectivités
territoriales sur la révision des
valeurs locatives
est-ce que c'est prévu est ce que c'est
à l'ordre du jour pour réviser ses
valeurs locatives qui permettrait
d'augmenter taxe d'habitation taxe
foncière alors absolument le
gouvernement a prévu la révision des
valeurs locatives
mais ce sera fait après la mise en place
de la taxe d'habitation parce que on ne
veut pas qu'il y ait confusion entre la
réforme de la taxe d'habitation et la
révision des valeurs locatives
ce sera en deux temps ça sera en deux
temps deux petites questions là sur
twitter à propos on parle des
départements des régions il ya eva sur
twitter avec le hashtag donc audition
publique qui nous dit le vrai grand défi
c'est plutôt de fer baissés des dépenses
exorbitantes du mille feuilles des
collectivités locales vous souvenez il
ya quelques années on disait il ya un
échelon trop c'est le département est ce
que c'est encore vrai non attendez pas
menacé le gouvernement s'est engagé à
une stabilité institutionnelle
il l'a dit dès le départ et d'autre part
je voudrais répondre 7
dav eva que nous avons avec les
collectivités territoriales pas c'est ce
qu'on appelle les contrats de cahors qui
est une l'engagement de la limitation de
l'augmentation des dépenses de
fonctionnement et que l'ensemble des
collectivités territoriales l'on
respecté donc il ya plus de problème de
mille feuille territorial c'est pas
qu'il ya pas de problème de mille
feuille territorial la france et ce
qu'elle est elle à la tradition qu'elle
a et puis je vais vous dire avec le
découpage qui a été fait des grandes
régions
je dirais que le gouvernement qui a fait
le découpage des grandes régions qui
vont soit hollande souffrent soit lent
et qui voulait lui même pendant un temps
faire disparaître les départements en
faisant les grandes régions ils ont
conforté les départements on disait
souffrance au lancé manuel valls très
clairement donc fêter ça a été une
erreur
ah mais moi je pense que ces grandes
région ont conforté effectivement les
départements mais en soi de fait
conforté de fête et de fait les
départements et je pense que certaines
régions sont comment dire très grande
voir trop grand par exemple par exemple
prenons nouvelle aquitaine
moi qui suis delà du centre val de loire
j'ai comme voisin l'indre juste après
c'est la creuse la creuse est un nouvel
aquitaine c'est quand même très loin
devant google mais pourquoi vous
intéressez pas vous le gouvernement 1re
découpage des régions à ce que ça ne
tient pas persuadé a pas quand ça marche
par wade c'est pas que ça ne tient pas
où ça marche pas ça il ya des
inconvénients
il ya des avantages peut-être mais il ya
des inconvénients et je pense que
changer sans arrêt les institutions ça
coûte beaucoup d'argent et deuxièmement
ça déstabilise d'une manière générale
les élus et ça empêche le fonctionnement
d'écoles et de l'ordre qui devait y
avoir plusieurs milliards d'économies à
l'issue de cette cette réforme des
grandes régions et finalement il n'y a
pas eu les économies attendues
vous avez vu vous avez lu le rapport de
la cour de couleur rapport de la cour
des comptes
donc vous pourriez décider de revenir
dessus oui mais encore une fois
l'instabilité c'est quelque chose qui
est extrêmement pénible et tous les élus
quand nous sommes arrivés au pouvoir
tous les élus nous demandez pas de
réforme
s'il vous plaît arrêter les réformes ce
qu'il faut voir qui en a eu une en 2010
en 2014 en 2015 je pourrais vous citer
tous les noms vous les connaissez rct
map tam notre ombre en plus rien d'eux
voilà donc un juste pas terminée avant
de laisser ta mai et brigitte partir
vous savez que vous savez depuis 2013
les listes dans les communes de plus de
1000 et 2000 habitants sont obligatoires
pour les municipales elles ont toutes
une étiquette politique le ministre de
l'intérieur prévoit lui de supprimer la
filiation politique pour les petites
communes sauf qu'il n'a pas dit à quel
seuil à quel seuil ça serait intéressant
de ne pas avoir d'étiquette politique
que ce serait pertinent
je sais il a dit dans une question
d'actualité au sénat
je n'ai pas noté qu'il n'avait pas dix
de seuil
non mais bon peut-être 9000 milles et
pas il faut il faut regarder de toute
façon il ya deux types vous savez de
deux modes d'élection il ya les listes
bloquées lewiston panachage faut
regarder c'est peut être ça fait
peut-être ça la limite 3500 tours et
3500 habitants ce serait la base il est
là mais bon à voir et à voir à discuter
je démarre mais acquise et décider tout
seul ce soir sur votre plateau non mais
vous pourriez avoir une idée 3500 j'ai
dit entre les deux formes de nos listes
merci thème traduit bien si brigitte
boucher et alan est évidemment un
auditions publiques
je vous attends et auditions publiques
c'est aussi le lieu de débat les
parlementaires on va accueillir deux
d'entre eux maintenant jamais en tentant
[Musique]
les parlementaires qui nous rejoignent
qui vont vous interrogez jacqueline
gourault c'est christophe bouillon
bonsoir député ps de seine maritime on
est en direct vous avez été ric et rac 1
veut travers un peu de retard si j'ai
contre si ça arrive tu tiens d'ailleurs
on va peut-être parler des petites
lignes au passage vous êtes à la tête de
la mission d'information de l'assemblée
nationale sur l'explosion de l'usiné
lubrizol à rouen et président de
l'association des petites villes de
france
ça va de 2500 à 25000 exact voilà et
mathieu darnaud est à vos côtés bonsoir
vous êtes sénateur et l'air de l'ardèche
et secrétaire général adjoint de l air
en tout cas pour jusqu'à quelques jours
peut-être encore sa filiale nouveau
président ou l air mais ça on va y
revenir tout à l'heure et bien puisqu'on
parlait du brise hall notamment c'est
dans l'actualité qui sauvent bouillon va
commencer oui madame est mise vous êtes
la mise de la cohésion du territoire
quand est ce qu'on va arrêter finalement
d'opposer le rural à l'urbain
quand on est en territoire rural à la
campagne on se plaint souvent que tout
est en ville les meilleurs services les
meilleures formations les meilleurs
emplois et souvent il ya une tentation
qui existent en ville c'est de se
débarrasser de ce qu'on ne veut pas voir
et de suite au terrible accident de
lubrizol à rouen il ya une petite
musique qui est en train de se jouer
aujourd'hui où certains se disent
finalement ses usines d'automesure
parfois le risque et dont on voit
aujourd'hui les effets il faudrait les
mettre ailleurs
et d'ailleurs certains pensent en rural
je crois que c'est pas une bonne
solution
j'aimerais surtout vous entendre sur la
persistance parfois des fractures
territoriales entre le rural et l'urbain
sur cette première question lubrizol est
ce qu'il faut des usines comme sa
dangereuse les envoyer à l'extérieur non
je ne crois pas d'ailleurs on pourrait
on peut aussi dire que quand cette usine
a été construite elle n'était pas au
milieu des habitations et parce que
l'urbanisation souvent vient se mettre
après les installations des usines et je
crois que c'est le cas vous connaissez
mieux que moi ce c'est ce site quand on
les fait
voilà mes seins quand on lui fait que
voilà moi je connais chez moi d
classée seveso qui était à la campagne
comme vous dites
enfin un peu à l'extérieur de la ville
et qui maintenant part je dirais
l'extension de l'urbanisation se
retrouvent davantage proche des voix là
c'est aussi un problème d'urbanisation
enfin avec le risque en tout cas les
usines sont là il faut surtout qu'il y
est il ya un contrôle régulier qui est
fait sur toutes les usines qui sont
classés seveso pour pour rouen ça a été
vérifiée il ya eu beaucoup de contrôles
qui ont été faits mais un accident est
toujours possible c'est ce qui est
arrivé et vous malgré tout favorable à
une somme de renforcement en fait des
contrôles parce qu'on voit bien qu'il ya
une tentation aussi très forte
aujourd'hui d'assouplissement dans tous
les domaines sous prétexte qu'il y
aurait trop de normes que ça serait plus
long ici qu'ailleurs de faire des
projets industriels ou autre parfois on
baisse la garde
j'ai le sentiment que ce que les
citoyens attendent aujourd'hui au
contraire c'est que on lâche pas prise
et qu'on soit d'une exigence absolue
vis-à-vis des industriels
mais je suis d'accord avec vous et c'est
toute l'ambiguïté des normes parce que
tout le monde se plaint qu'il y a trop
de normes mais il y à des normes qui
sont nécessaires et des normes qui sont
nécessaires pour la sécurité des
habitants mais les normes sont
nécessaires pour la sécurité des enfants
etc
et donc il ya une espèce de leitmotiv
sur les normes tout le monde en crée
d'ailleurs déjà en main mais il faut
faire attention effectivement est ce
qu'on fait c'est comme les charges un
peu hein ben voilà mathieu darnaud vous
vous êtes élu rural en ardèche et vous
avez en face la ministre des
collectivités locales qu'est ce que vous
allez on lui donne envie de lui demander
ma question elle est très claire on
vient d'assister à la crise des filets
jaunes a suivi par le grand débat
national et tous convergent pour dire
qu'aujourd'hui il faut et c'est l'objet
du prochain texte plus de
décentralisation plus de déconcentration
de faire en sorte finalement que cette
proximité que nos concitoyens appellent
de leurs voeux puisse se traduire par
cette déconcentration et cette
décentralisation nous avons nous
examinons actuellement au sénat le texte
engagement et proximité et un texte
l'aveu même du ministre le corps nu qui
a été largement
inspiré par le sénat pour essayer de
redonner confiance aux élus mais le fond
ce sera essentiellement ce texte des
concentrations différenciation et est-ce
que vous pouvez nous dire aujourd'hui si
ce sera un texte de plus un texte
cosmétiques ou si on va aller vraiment
vers une vraie décentralisation qui
permettra de redonner du pouvoir local y
compris en matière de territoires ruraux
j'ai pas tout à fait répondu mais on
pourrait parler de l'agenda rural mais
on va d'abord à la pudeur nous parce que
mathieu hier j'ai écouté jean pierre
raffarin qui était sur une radio
nationale
j'étais très contente de l'entendre
puisque jean pierre raffarin fait une
étape de la décentralisation bien sûr en
2003 après les grandes lois sous le
président mitterrand les lois defferre
et il a dit cette phrase alors peut-être
pas exact mais l'idée je voulais je vous
la city l'a dit maintenant la
décentralisation il faut une nouvelle
forme de décentralisation et avec la
contractualisation il a prononcé ce mot
et vous savez que c'est quelque chose
qui m'est cher je crois que la
décentralisation qu'on doit faire
maintenant elle doit être fait dans le
temps une france qui est ce qu'elle est
qu'elle est déjà décentralisée avec des
beaucoup de compétences aux
collectivités territoriales il y en a
encore très certainement à transférer
que bras par exemple les départements
aimerait bien avoir des routes
nationales qui sont encore et quand je
dis ça les moyens on peut voir parce que
la grande allée là on a reproché à des
centrales mais la décentralisation s'est
accompagné la première fois et la
deuxième fois des moyens qui ont été
transférées c'est pas nous qui étions au
pouvoir
c'était des majorités auquel vous
appartenez d'ailleurs et moi aussi
d'ailleurs à l'est pas donc il faut dire
les choses telles qu'elles sont et
évidemment les moyens
ça va avec mais tout de suite je prends
l'exemple des routes pour vous dire et
c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est que
certains départements réclament des
routes et d'autres ne veulent pas alors
qu'il va trancher et ben non parce qu'on
on peut dès maintenant mais qui
trancheront
imaginez que la contractualisation est
quelque chose de très important
si le président du conseil général de la
savoie qui vient m'expliquer que dans
une vallée il ya une route qui est à
bout départementale 1 vous national et
re départemental il veut avoir le goût
non c'est normal c'est ça que c'est ce
que vous appelez la différenciation
jacquin chaque cas est différent là-bas
c'est à dire que par contre dans des
départements très ruraux très pauvre si
vous leur dites on va vous donner une
route nationale ils n'en veulent pas
parce que ils ont pas pour l'instant là
les moyens suffisants même s'il y a une
décentralisation avec des moyens ils ont
peur de se chargent de cette charge
mais je m'empresse de dire tout de suite
que ce qu'il faut c'est à sortir ce
débat d'une pré matic constitutionnel
est ce qu'il y aura une réforme de la
constitution parce que moi j'ai une
route nationale 102 en ardèche
aujourd'hui personne n'en veut parce
qu'on sait que oui où elle va entre la
haute loire et la vallée du rhône
c'est un axe qui est fondamentale mais
aujourd'hui on connaît les coûts et même
l'état ne veut pas investir à hauteur de
ce qui serait nécessaire en termes de
sécurisation
si demain on décide pas d'accompagner
cette déconcentration cette
décentralisation d'un principe qui est
tout simple qu'on doit ce qu'ils ont
dans la constitution qui décident paye
alors je le dis on va au devant de
sujets qui vont être expliquer parce
qu'on va transférer les charges mais on
ne transférera pas les ressources
nécessaires et là je pense qu'on fait de
l'aménagement du territoire à l'envers
donc c'est vraiment pour moi une source
d'inquiétude et dernier point c'est sur
les normes parce que ça c'est un vrai
sujet c'est d'abord et peut-être jeu
king où elle sut sortir ça nous avons ça
va en même temps donc ça si vous me le
permettez sur les normes
est-ce qu'on va vers la généralisation
des préfet simplificateur qui pourront
avoir une lecture assoupli et
territorialisée de la norme parce que ça
c'est une vraie réponse concrète pour
aller les préfectures et la main et la
main pour assouplir ou pour lire de
façon assoupli la nord alors il ya deux
questions vous pouvez y répondre à la
première question il a toujours été la
rive en constitutionnel non la première
question là toujours il avait déjà bien
entendu la première question il a
toujours été prévu que quand il y avait
décentralisation y avait les moyens qui
s'accompagnait toujours et c'est déjà
dans les lois de décentralisation bon
deuxièmement sur les préfets
il ya une expérience qui est fait
aujourd'hui pour donner au préfet le
droit effectivement à l'adaptation si je
puis dire de la réglementation c'est
très important
nous avons une expérience qui est assez
positive et je souhaite à titre
personnel qu'elle soit étendue
effectivement à l'ensemble des préfets
christophe bouillon vous parce que la
ministre parlait de la janais rural j on
va y revenir et ça c'est votre dossier
j'allais dire puisque l'association des
petites villes de france de l'effet des
propositions tout à fait 200 alors vous
allez peut-être prendre une ou deux puis
interrogé la ministre là dessus oui
puisque me le permettait c'est vrai que
la saison 2 du quinquennat c'est la
saison des territoires et vous avez
ouvert cette saison des territoires avec
en mettant sur la table cet agenda râle
auxquels nous avons participé
c'est vrai que pierre jarlier qui le
président délégué de la paix vf
il ya 200 propositions serait trop long
de les évoquer
j'ai dit voilà une ou deux pour répondre
à la commande la première est ce que
vous êtes prêt et quand à mettre en
place dans les territoires aux des
emplois francs la deuxième question
parce que ça passait rien la première
action c'est à dire la 22e après emplois
francs parce que ça c'est ce viol car
ils sont ciblés par exactement pour
faire gagner raison de taxes
exactement il faut créer de l'emploi
aussi dans les territoires ruraux je ne
vais pas vous répondre aussi précisément
que vous le souhaiteriez parce que c'est
un dossier que nous sommes en train
d'étudier pour voir si c'est
transposable dans la ruralité on a
d'excellents c'est un peu compliqué on a
d'excellents résultats dans un dans le
nord en particulier dans tout ce qui est
agglomération enfin métropole pardon
lilloise nous avons ailleurs ou de moins
bons résultats donc nous sommes en train
de fermer parce que le principe des
nouveaux emplois francs c'est un
principe qui fait que quel que soit le
lieu de l'entreprise c'est la provenance
d
des salariés ou des futurs salariés qui
compte avant dans l'ancien régime des
emplois france était le lieu de
l'entreprise qui comptait donc il faut
regarder par rapport aux entreprises à
part l'ambassade emploi cie s'est
transposée en milieu rural les gens
peuvent venir de très loin pour
travailler ça faut regarder d'accord
alors plus simple question est les 15000
emplois civique ou pourrait créer dans
les territoires ruraux à destination à
la fois des personnes âgées mais aussi
des collectivités
c'est avec beaucoup de communes ou lui à
souffrir et notamment les petites villes
de la disparition des emplois aidés pour
des raison simple c'est que c'était
assez facile c'était un emploi de
proximité
et puis ça a aidé bien la commune et ça
permettait de le financer assez
simplement et moi je pense que l'idée
qui figurent dans l'agenda rural des
15000 emplois civique se mettre moins
compliqué sans doute un peu feront plus
direct mais il faut que ça se fasse
maintenant il faut que ça se passe non
mais ça c'est pas les emplois civique
c'est quelque chose que nous soutenons
quels que soient les lieux quelles que
soient les les territoires je voudrais
simplement revenir sur ce qu'a dit au
début le député c'est que je suis
d'accord avec lui sur le fait qu'il faut
jamais opposé l'oral et l'urbain parce
que ça c'est quelque chose de mortels et
mathieu sait très bien commencé pendant
des années j'ai posé cette idée est par
ailleurs par rapport à l'agenda rural il
y a beaucoup de puisque le gouvernement
a retenu 173 proposition alors y'en a
qui vont se mettre en place plus ou
moins rapidement bien évidemment mais il
y a des par exemple j'ai signé
d'ailleurs avec l'association de
christophe bouillon
l'idée au fond de faire aussi un plan
entre guillemets pour les petites villes
qui font centralité dans la ruralité et
ça c'est quelque chose de très important
c'est à dire de soutenir le petit
commerce de soutenir l'habitat dans les
petits coeur de bourg
c'est quelque chose de très important
êtes-vous prêts à nous aider sur la
désertification médicale
il ya une proposition qui figure dans
cet agenda que je trouve pertinente
c'est de favoriser pour les internes des
stages de fin d'études dans les
territoires ruraux savait que les maires
aujourd'hui savent plus comment faire
ils ont multiplié les initiatives des
petites annonces ils ont employé
directement des médecins fait des
maisons de santé nous voit bien
aujourd'hui que malheureusement ça le
fait pas progresser
en tout cas ça ne met your pas la
situation au contraire elle continue à
se dégrader notamment territoire rural
là dessus ça on peut le faire rapidement
oui il ya même une autre mais je dis oui
avec toi imposée parce qu'on n'ose pas
l'imposer c'est compliqué de l'imposer
mais il faut développer ces stages parce
que là ce qu'on voit après c'est que pas
toujours mais que les stagiaires qui
viennent travailler aux côtés d'un
médecin souvent bas y prennent goût au
territoire en calissons il reste et puis
il ya une autre mesure dans le même
domaine de la désertification médicale
qui est une réalité dans notre pays
le gouvernement avait annoncé la
création de 400 médecins salariés pour
les envoyer en urgence si je puis dire
dans les zones sous-dotées et l'agenda
rural proposé par l'équipe qui a
travaillé sur la jeanne d'arc grade
propose que nous montions à 6 ans et
nous acceptons cette proposition
maintenant oui comme je suis un peu têtu
je reviens sur l'idée date des
concentrations parce que ça accompagné
ça prolonge ce que disait à mon collègue
député à l'instant aujourd'hui on sent
bien que les besoins on en a
véritablement une utilité sur les
territoires et quand je parle de besoin
je parle de besoins humains et de moyens
humains est-ce que la déconcentration
est ce que ce texte souhaité par le
président de la république sera
l'occasion de re dire qu'aujourd'hui
pour que justement cet écart entre
l'urbain et le rural ne se creuse pas
nous
demain une déconcentration utile avec
des moyens pour justement permettre de
résorber cette problématique de la
désertification médicale
la question qui s'ouvre aujourd'hui avec
les problèmes des trésoreries des
services publics en milieu rural
je crois que c'est un acte un acte fort
mais aujourd'hui il y a encore beaucoup
de fous donc est-ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire un peu plus sur ce sujet là il
ya la loi elle n'est pas écrite et la
loi on va la construire ensemble alors
donc ses cheveux pas mais on va la
construire ensemble on va commencer le
travail maintenant mais je peux déjà
vous parler d'un certain nombre de
choses france service c'est une réalité
et déjà que nous sommes en train de
réaliser sur les territoires maison
c'est ce public
oui c'est ça y'en a combien alors activé
aujourd'hui il y en a mille trois cent
quarante et la volonté du président de
la république de transformer en france
service c'est de monter en gamme la
qualité des services publics sur les
territoires et souvent je dirais en
accord avec les élus locaux y sommes
c'est à dire ben c'est à dire qui et on
a mis une charte si vous voulez qui doit
être respectée parce que dans les
maisons de services au public existe
aujourd'hui et vous le savez comme moi
il ya différentes qualités il ya des
maisons de services au public qui ne
méritent pas je dirais d'être appelée
maison de ses émotions qu'ils ont peur
parce que il n'y a pas assez de présence
des opérateurs des ministères qui
doivent être présents nous avons mis
donc une espèce de charte qui doit
respecter tout cela pour labelliser
france service et nous allons développer
de nouvelles maisons l' agence nationale
de cohésion des territoires cher mathieu
darnaud c'est pour remettre sur les
territoires des fonctionnaires et ça
c'est quelque chose de très important et
vous savez que le président de la
république à redonner un sens à la
départementalisation des de la fonction
publique d'état
on a tous peut-être ça je crois me
rappeler ce a souffert d'une
régionalisation à l'excès pendant
longtemps
donc l'idée c'est de remettre au coeur
des territoires que sont les
départements l'ingénierie nécessaire et
notamment l' agence nationale de
cohésion du territoire dont chaque
problème département sera la porte
d'entrée une question de
téléspectatrices al attiyah 27 ans
beaucoup plus simple vous allez voir
mais vous aussi cela vous concerne et
pourquoi est-ce qu'on paie toujours une
taxe d'habitation élevé malgré la baisse
de la taxe à bien la taxe vous allez
pouvoir répondre parce que vous aussi
vous êtes dedans
la taxe d'habitation est enfin va
disparaître pour 80% des français en
2020 en 2020 et ensuite pour les 20%
restants puisque ça a été comment dire
étendu à l'ensemble des français suite à
la remarque du conseil constitutionnel
de l'égalité devant l'impôt
donc pourquoi ça continue d'augmenter ah
mais ça ne peut pas augmenter là c'est
ce que dit pourquoi petton toujours une
taxe d'habitation élevé malgré la baisse
de la taxe alors peut-être que cette
dame peut se trouver dans une aile et
peut-être dans les 20 % ou sa famille et
dans les 20% dernier et que la pauvre
fille d'armande et que la commune a
augmenté les taux c'est ça que je vois
vous craignez pas vous élus locaux que
la fin d'un taxe d'habitation ce soit
justement l'occasion pour certains élus
d'augmenter les taxes foncières par
exemple les taxes locales
parce qu'ils n'ont pas le choix vous
craignez pas ça vous que l'équipe à l'
approche sa dette est en jeu quand on
regarde les choses concrètement il ya
très peu de communes ou les impôts
augmentent comme ça par automaticité
c'est plutôt contraire général notre
notation des appeaux elle correspond
souvent à besoin vous voulez construire
une salle des fêtes voulait un service
renforcé
il ya un projet qui s'attache derrière
d'ailleurs c'est la raison pour laquelle
au nom de la paix vf on pense que
quelque part c'était un impôt citoyen
parce que les habitants de ces
territoires
arriver à comprendre finalement qu'est
ce qu'on faisait de leur argent ils se
disaient oui je paye des impôts en même
temps je vois à quoi correspond ce que
ses impôts à ce propos il ya gérard
larcher président du sénat qui a déclaré
l'autre jour que c'était un problème de
citoyenneté quand même de ne plus payer
l'impôt d'une plus payer la taxe
d'habitation il dit lui quand il n'ya
plus de liens financiers entre ce qui
est dépensé par une commune
est ce que les gens peuvent payer selon
leur mort selon leur contribution
possible ça pose un problème
démocratique qu'est ce que vous lui
répondez
je réponds que
il y aura une nouvelle ressource qui est
le foncier bâti qui descendent des
départements vers les communes et que
les communes auront donc toujours un
lien avec leurs citoyens
papa autant bien sûr que la taxe
d'habitation
deuxièmement il ya d'autres moyens
d'avoir des liens avec les citoyens qui
participent aussi aux services publics
d'une autre manière
et puis il faut savoir aussi que il y
avait déjà allé à peu près 25 à 30% des
gens en france qui ne paient pas ou qui
ne paient plus la taxe d'habitation
ils n'ont jamais été considérés comme
des non citoyens ou des sous citoyens ou
des soucis seront mathieu mathieu
darnaud oui moi je considère que l'impôt
est des cons substantiel du pacte
républicain ça va avec alors qu'on
supprime une taxe dans l'absolu pourquoi
pas le souci c'est que c'est exactement
ce que vous avez dit il ne va rester que
la taxe foncière
or selon les différentes communes vous
avez plus ou moins de propriétaires est
donc plus ou moins de gens qui
s'acquitte de la taxe foncière donc là
aussi vous allez créer une inégalité
entre les communes tout ça c'est
important et je pense que
malheureusement ne répond pas à cette
question et ça va poser un problème
aussi de dynamique de recettes par
rapport aux différentes sélections est
un témoignage la part de national oui
peut-être dire quelque chose que je n'ai
pas dit qu'on rappelle quand même parce
qu'il ya l'entrée collectivités
territoriales c'est normal qu'on parle
de ça nous ici ce que je suis la
ministre est que ce sont des élus mais
faut jamais oublier aussi que la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation
c'est 17 milliards d'économies pour les
français c'est des baisses d'impôts mais
faut-il encore qu'on ne leur verse pas
ou qu'on oblige les maires à ne pas
augmenter la taxe foncière
ça c'est un vrai sujet aussi l'activité
le ciel sera une ressource dynamique en
facilitant la peau nationale n'est pas
suffisamment de compans ailleurs vous
aurez il ne faut pas qu'ils se soient
qu'elle dirait l'autre sensation
bretagne
pour l'instant il ya ce qu'on appelle on
est dans la période du dégrèvement c'est
à dire que c'est l'état qui paie à la
place du contribuable et puis ensuite il
y a la phase la réforme se met en place
un jeu c'est un peu compliqué je parlais
dans le détail mais les communes seront
compensées à l'ordre et la ressource
radine m alors les communes vont être
compensés parce que les communes vont
recevoir des taxes qui était touché par
le département le département à la place
d'un receveur de la tva est ce que tout
ça c'est une espèce d'une usine à gaz
qui est en train de mettre en place plus
personne n'y comprend rien on est contre
et contre immeuble qui sait même plus
pourquoi ils payent quand un impôt le
foncier bâti est prélevée par deux
collectivités voire trois aussi donc
c'est pas une collectivité mais la
commune l'intercommunalité et le
département vous croyez que ça lisible
moi je me souviens quand les
départements ont augmenté les impôts de
façon importante
c'était à cause de la crise de 2008 ils
n'ont pas inventé pour fair play pour se
faire plaisir il y avait une véritable
crise est bien où est ce que les gens
aller râler
il n'est pas allé au département parce
que l'impôt le foncier bâti
tous les français vous pouvez faire un
micro trottoir pense que c'est le maire
sait les mairies qui lève donc mettre un
impôt à un même niveau de collectivités
territoriales moi je trouve que c'est
plus clair c'est plus clair voilà la
question de l'autonomie financière dire
c'est garanti par la constitution et
c'est vrai que c'est une demande très
forte et c'est normal des communes ou
des collectivités en général de pouvoir
exercer des compétences en se donnant
les moyens et un ayant des choix
politiques aussi c'est vrai que qu'est
ce qui différencie une commune d'une
autre ou un département d'un autre c'est
la politique on est mieux en place et
pour mettre ces politiques en place il
faut bien qu'on ait une forme
d'autonomie financière
je pense que là il ya quand même un
enjeu démocratique nigérien alors en
termes de quantité si je puis dire vous
aurez la même ressource qu'avant c'est
clair et net
avec quand même une difficulté que l'on
sait c'est qu'il ya beaucoup
d'attribution de subventions aux
communes qui sont liés j'ai envie de
dire à ce qu'on appelait le potentiel
fiscal va pas rentrer dans les détails
mais c'est quand même mais ma notion
important qu'il y est les élus c'est un
travail qui va lui falloir qu'on fasse
ensemble et j'ai déjà saisi le cfl pour
ça le comité des finances locales qui
est présidée par monsieur andré league
donc tour pour rassurer nos
parlementaires qui sont là vous
garantissez que les collectivités
locales auront les mêmes ressources
louis le même argent qu aujourd'hui oui
même plus parce que sedin a plus ce
formidable est ce que le manceau
département parce que est ce que les
communes dans les onze jeunes semaine
pourront avoir pour chacune d'entre
elles une simulation alors c'est un
moment très fort et très sains
c'est arrivé dans tous les départements
vous pouvez demander au département l'a
envoyé au président de l'assemblée
nationale et on l'a envoyée au groupe
donc normalement donc l'économie devrait
avoir ça mais voilà ici sinon ce
département votre chaîne d'info en rss
et il vous la donnerai aux préfets pour
toutes les communes les simulations
merci mathieu darnaud merci christophe
bouillon d'avoir été sur le plateau
d'auditions publiques première de cette
saison merci et bon courage pour la
suite de vos travaux
on va accueillir maintenant yves thréard
et il serait sot figaro le regard
distrait un bon soir yves une question
de téléspectateurs avant c'est une
question sur voila c'est tout simple
c'est mythique i / le figaro nous dit la
maternité de mon village a été fermée la
poste vient de fermer la côte c'est la
commune qui reprend le service
il ne reste plus rien c'est vrai ça
c'est du c'est du vécu ça existe bien
sûr tout ce que vous venez de dire là
pendant un quart d'heure cette dame par
exemple oui habitants des villages
cette dame elle se dit mais alors moi ça
change rien pour nos clients c'est à
dire monsieur jeu comment vous dire les
faits sont là ils sont têtus comme on
dit mais peut-être dire je vous dise a
très gentiment que c'est pas quelque
chose qui s'est fait en deux ans la
fermeture de tous les commerces etc
c'est une évolution qui s'est fait avec
l'exode rural avec enfin tout le monde
sait ça ça fait trente ans quarante ans
que l'on voit l'évolution et
l'urbanisation etc
alors aujourd'hui vous avez un
gouvernement qu'ils puis deux ans essaie
d'apporter des réponses à cette
situation
yves thréard alors vous avez écouté
l'émission depuis le début vous avez des
choses à vous dire évidemment vous allez
tirer des conclusions et je les
questions qui vont venir évidemment sur
bonsoir jacqueline soit alors c'est
intéressant de vous écouter parce que
quand on vous écoute on se dit mais le
président de la république qui a été
attaqué par les gilet jaune parce qu'ils
étaient trop jupitérien même par
l'opposition mais il aurait dû vous
mettre en avant depuis le début parce
que vous êtes l'incarnation justement de
tout sauf paris d'une certaine façon
alors j'en veux pour preuve qu'il ya un
mot vous avez
prononcez c'est le bo de contrat quand
on est en contractualisation c'est ce
que vous l'option que vous privilégiez
comme jean pierre raffarin d'ailleurs eh
ben on est par définition
opposé à l'imposition depuis paris et
d'ailleurs ce qui est intéressant c'est
que on se dit que vous n'êtes pas
tellement favorable à l'exercice
législatif vous avez vu sur le voile
notamment dans les assemblées vous dites
mais il faut que chacun s'arrange chez
soi mais il ne faut pas légiférer en
plus je sais pas si vous avez raison sur
ce quoi là c'est pas je parlais pas des
territoires je parlais des deux
assemblées mais vous vous êtes pas vous
êtes acharné législatives et vous n'êtes
pas eu un charme et de la loi vous êtes
très contractuels première chose et
c'est peut-être comme ça d'ailleurs
qu'il faut mener la décentralisation
dont une loi est annoncée l'année
prochaine est ce qu'il y en a besoin
d'une loi
vous nous direz peut-être à l'occasion
la deuxième chose qui me marque en vous
écoutant c'est que vous êtes à la droite
finalement de la majorité présidentielle
et vous êtes à la droite du président de
la république
deux exemples la première sur le voile
vous avez de même discours que blanc
caire qui vient ma droite même discours
que ciotti qui vient de la droite
si si si si si mais pas du tout même
discours que si ben ndiaye première
chose deuxième chose sur la pma voyez
dire que j'ai le même discours que
bayrou c'est bah oui vient d'annoncer
tout à fait maître discours c'est la
révélation vous avez fait que que
emmanuel macron sur certains sujets vous
avez dit qu'ils n'étaient pas toujours
en accord
on peut vous considérez vous êtes plutôt
à droite 1 ça m'amène à ma première
question chère jacqueline gourault est
ce que vous êtes contente
est-ce que ça paraît logique de
christian jacob soient élus prennent
très majoritairement président des
républicains
écoutez je trouve que c'est la victoire
d'abord d'un fidèle à sa famille
politique
et moi j'aime bien ça c'est la victoire
d'un militant au sens vrai du terme
parce que c'est un militant moi j'ai
connu jacob militants agricole méfaits
de syndicalistes agricoles fnsea
je me souviens de réunions oui
c'est un gars avait tancé récemment à
l'assemblée bad en lui disant vous ne
tenez pas votre troupe monsieur le
président du groupe je suis pas sûr si
on se demande alors si c'est vrai je les
dis alors
mais il faut s'affirmer face à jacob
parce que c'est une personnalité il a de
la voix etc
donc il faut ça avec lui mais je vais
terminer
c'est un fidèle c'est un militant qui a
été bien formés parce que le
syndicalisme agricole a formé beaucoup
de grands hommes politiques
et puis je crois je suis sûre même que
c'est un républicain d'accord alors
c'est un républicain au sens premier du
terme mais pour les républicains parce
que les républicains avec lui peuvent
renaître de leurs cendres
ça c'est l'heure leur mission et c'est
sa mission
ces jeunes et je n'ai jamais appartenu à
cette famille politique
bien entendu je pense que la mission
de christian jacob s'est de refédérer sa
famille est ce que vous croyez
aujourd'hui que les républicains ont un
avenir électoral prochain aux
municipales par exemple par exemple se
refaire une santé
d'abord je crois que il ya des élus
républicains qui vont être réélu parce
que ils sont mères c'est pas forcément
parce qu'ils sont républicains c'est
parce qu'ils sont maîtres républicain on
sent ce appartenance nous encourager la
majorité présidentielle va faire
alliance avec eux pour gagner des
mairies il y as républicain est
républicain quand vous le savez et c'est
le problème du parti justement on voit
très bien que c'était de nous le
christian estrosi et quad il faut enfin
il faut être derrière lui mais je vois
c'est pas moi qui vais décider sur des
derrière christian est ce que vous
verrez un icône estrosi j'ai siégé à
l'association des maires de france
depuis très longtemps je connais estrosi
je considère que c'est un républicain
je tends républicains de vouloir
s'allier avec lui mais je ne sais pas
dit qu'il fallait ça y est j'ai vécu là
je vais aller savait plus s'il ya des
pauvres et peu denses et voilà et puis
il y en a d'autres où vraiment je pense
qu'il faudrait même pas s'approcher mais
qui va avec nous non non je peux pas
vous dire non
voici non vous n'êtes pas très
courageuse alors à vous trouver cru donc
prudente d'accord pour juste une petite
formation yves qu'on en apprend que
gérard collomb vient d'être investi par
la république en marche pour se
présenter à la métropole de lyon donc ça
laisse tout ouvert pour le reste la
formation qu'il faut compléter par le
fait que monsieur qui mal fait
est encouragée par l'ancien maire de
lyon qui avait remplacé monsieur collomb
pour justement être le président de la
métropole vous n'avez pas fini il a un
ça va être compliqué oui enfin jusqu'à
preuve du contraire c'est pas moi qui
règle les problèmes du parti en marche
puisque vous avez je suis modem alors je
peux pas régler les problèmes d'actions
alors justement vous êtes modem nous
avait appartenu à la une majorité ancien
qui était quand même majorité de droite
vous l'avez même si vous avez tout à
lire vos distances avec les républicains
la droite et les ou aujourd'hui c'est
vous qui l'incarné pas vous jacqueline
gourault mais la majorité présidentielle
je crois que la majorité présidentielle
est une majorité centrale et qu' elle a
su rassembler des gens qui venaient de
la droite et de la gauche le langage est
basse et des éléments n'étaient pas des
réformes sont plutôt de droite non sur
le plan économique non les réformes sont
des réformes bien pour la france est
bonne pour la france je ne sais pas ce
que c'est que des réformes de droite ou
des réformes de gauche à ce que les
retraites par exemple la révision des
réformes des retraites est ce que c'est
de droite ou de gauche jacques serre et
à répondre la droite ou de gauche c'est
pareil je ne sais pas beau bon ne
fallait pas répondre non est-ce que la
der à ce que je connais des gens qui
dans les deux catégories que vous
énoncez de grands étaient des gauches
sont favorables alors la réforme de la
pma et la réforme de la loi bioéthique
c'est une chose acquise vous pouvez vous
nous assurer que la réforme des
retraites sera fait d'ici à la fin du
quinquennat
je pense qu'elle sera fait oui avant la
partie festive servie à thatcher ou
aller elle est programmée de débats avec
deux ans et demi qu'on débat oui mais là
il ya un débat plus large qui s'ouvre
débat avec la population
débat avec les caisses les 42 caisses
les comme le garant le régime régime
particulier et donc il ya encore du
travail à faire mais qu'on soit la
réforme des retraites sera fait un
quinquennat
pareil pour la réforme de la
décentralisation qui doit s'engager à ce
niveau l'année prochaine aux pêcheurs
d'accord ce françois fillon a ironisé
quand même au passage dans une interview
à la radio télévision suisse récemment
en disant mais de toute façon emmanuel
macron il reculera sur la réforme des
retraites
il te ironisé d'accord alors il ya un
problème qui est central aujourd'hui en
france et qui concerne tous les français
c'est c'est loin certes baissé la guerre
en syrie avec l'offensive turque
d'abord première chose hier jean pierre
raffarin que vous citiez a dit j'ai des
doutes sur le lien transatlantique j'ai
l'impression que les états unis ont
lâché l'europe
oui on peut considérer que l'attitude
des états unis est une attitude
effectivement espèce de retrait subi des
troupes
oui fait qu'on se retrouve dans une
situation de déséquilibre par rapport
aux forces en présence et effectivement
on peut je suis d'accord exemple après
il ya un deuxième problème qui se pose
en dehors de tout géopolitique c'est
qu'il ya des djihadistes de nationalité
française et d'autres nationalités
européennes qui sont là bas comme les
kurdes
pressé par les turcs sont allés ont
relâché la plupart des prisonniers
qu'ils avaient fait de dèche parce que
c'est eux qui ont lutté contre bêche
ces jihadistes est ce que vous n'avez
pas peur qu'ils reviennent
redoutez vous pas qu'ils reviennent sur
le continent européen et notamment bien
sûr le président de la république l'a
dit vous savez qu'il a fait un conseil
de défense et de sécurité
dimanche soir oui c'est ça et vous avez
vu le président de la république l'a dit
notre priorité c'est de lutter contre
les forces de neige qui peuvent être
effectivement comme vous le venez de le
décrire parfaitement avoir été dans le
la guerre qui s'y passe les
bombardements qu'il soit jugé
ces jihadistes quand il ya des preuves
suffisantes sur place en france ou par
un tribunal comparable à celui de
nuremberg après la guerre je pense que
il faut d'abord s'assurer que les
djihadistes ne se propage pas et votre
question est de savoir quoi si on les
prend ou est-ce qu'ils sont jugés mais
dans notre vie reprenait audio nist oui
la france chez vous non c'est pas nos
djihadistes c'est des djihadistes tout
ce qui contre tout ce qui représente
l'occident donc ils sont autant aux
américains que nous avons parlé de ce
qu'ils sont de nationalité française
mais vous savez quelle était la position
du gouvernement
il y avait des djihadistes qui était la
leur a jamais été que vous savez je je
je laisse
enfin vous dit c'est pas clair je ne
sais pas pourquoi vous dites ça parce
que les djihadistes était jugé par les
forces locales
bien évidemment et parce que c'est forcé
lequel était aussi engagé dans la guerre
une seconde une seconde dans la question
on se dirige vers une élection avec un
duel emmanuel macron marine le pen ça
vous va pas je ne sais pas où vous savez
on ne peut jamais se réjouir de la
montée du front national ou de
l'existence du front national a une
place importante dans la vie politique
française
ça dongle qu emmanuel macron amis en
plaidant non mais c'est pas il a mis en
place il ya une réalité il ya des faits
dans la vie politique c'est tout ce
qu'on peut regarder
voilà merci il est rare d'avoir posé les
questions et soumis à l'interrogatoire
jacqueline gourault qui était la
première invitée deux auditions
publiques version 2019 2020
merci d'avoir été sur ses chaînes
parlementaires qui parle beaucoup des
territoires est normal vous soyez là
n'oubliez pas que vous pouvez retrouver
cette émission sur figaro live ainsi que
sur figaro.fr et sur les comptes twitter
lcp et public sénat
bonne semaine et à lagny prochain 19h
pour audition publique merci
[Musique]